It started as something that she was doing in her spare time and kind of took over her life. Lissa Yellow Bird searches for missing people, people nobody else is looking for, people the police have given up looking for. A reporter, Sierra Crane Murdoch, met Lissa in 2014 when Sierra was looking into the disappearance of a young, white oil worker, KC Clarke. He'd vanished a couple years before on the reservation Lissa's from in North Dakota. Lissa was investigating it too.
起初，这只是她业余时间做的事，后来却占据了她的生活。莉莎·黄鸟（Lissa Yellow Bird）会去寻找失踪人员，那些没人找的人，那些警察已经放弃寻找的人。记者塞拉·克兰·默多克（Sierra Crane Murdoch）在 2014 年结识了莉莎，当时塞拉正在调查一位年轻的白人石油工人 KC·克拉克（KC Clarke）的失踪案。他在几年前在莉莎的家乡——北达科他州的印第安保留地上失踪了。莉莎当时也在调查这起案件。
She had just gotten out of prison. She was looking for a distraction, a way to stay sober. And she basically opened up her files to me and allowed me to see the degree to which she had involved herself in this case.
她当时刚出狱。她正在寻找一种消遣方式，一种保持清醒的方法。她基本上向我公开了她的档案，让我看到了她参与这个案件的程度。
She had actually spent years. And she cracked that case through really, really non-traditional means, like by basically waging this campaign against the person who she believed had murdered KC Clarke. She mailed tens and tens of thousands of fliers around western North Dakota.
她实际上已经投入了多年。她通过非常非常规的手段破获了那个案子，比如基本上对她认为谋杀了 KC·克拉克的人发动了这场运动。她在北达科他州西部寄出了成千上万张传单。
The flyer said, "Beware", with a photo of the guy she thought murdered KC Clarke and his wife. And they did turn people against him. But at the same time, Lissa befriended the wife.
传单上写着“当心”，并附有她认为是杀害 KC·克拉克凶手的那个男人和他妻子的照片。他们确实让人对他产生了敌意。但与此同时，莉莎却与那个妻子成为了朋友。
They were texting each other almost every day. They were talking on the phone constantly. And so she had this really intimate window into the lives of these people she was trying to investigate.
她们几乎每天都在发短信。她们一直在通电话。因此，她有了一个非常私密的窗口，可以观察这些她试图调查的人的生活。
And through that window, she was able to see their vulnerabilities. So at the same time that she was maintaining this faux friendship with this woman, she was also completely undermining her and her husband. And the case broke open.
通过那个窗口，她得以看到他们的脆弱之处。所以，当她维持与这个女人的虚假友谊的同时，她也在彻底破坏她和她丈夫的生活。随后案件取得了突破。
Sierra spent years with Lissa, watching this play out, and ended up writing a book about Lissa and the case. They got close. Sierra would stay at Lissa's apartment for months. They'd drive through the badlands, running down leads, talked for hours every week when Sierra wasn't in North Dakota.
塞拉和莉莎相处了多年，观察着这一切的发展，并最终写了一本关于莉莎和这个案子的书。她们变得很亲近。塞拉会在莉莎的公寓里住上几个月。她们开车穿过荒地，追寻线索，每当塞拉不在北达科他州时，她们每周都会通几个小时的电话。
And during those years, this thing happened. Native American families started asking Lissa to look for their loved ones. Lissa's Arikara, a member of the Mandan Hidatsa Arikara Nation. Remember, Lissa was just kind of inventing how she did this work. Before this, she'd been a welder, a prison guard, a social worker, did some law enforcement work and studied criminal justice in college, but she'd also been a drug dealer.
而在这些年里，发生了一件事。美洲原住民家庭开始请求莉莎去寻找他们失踪的亲人。莉莎是阿里卡拉族（Arikara），是曼丹-希达莎-阿里卡拉民族（Mandan Hidatsa Arikara Nation）的一员。请记住，莉莎基本上是在摸索着做这项工作。在此之前，她当过电焊工、狱警、社会工作者，做过一些执法工作，并在大学学习过刑事司法，但她也曾是一名毒贩。
Lissa has lived on both sides of the law, which is what makes her so good at what she does. She's gone to prison. She knows how law enforcement operates from a perpetrator's point of view as well.
莉莎在法律的灰色地带生活过，这正是她为何如此擅长这份工作的原因。她坐过牢。她也从罪犯的角度了解执法部门是如何运作的。
In dozens of cases now, sometimes on her own, sometimes with law enforcement. Lissa has deployed the same doggedness and resourcefulness that she marshaled in that first case. Like, for example, when a woman named Olivia Lone Bear went missing from Lissa's reservation in 2017, there was this national search for her. But Lissa's theory was she might not be far from home, where she was last seen. And one day, she decided to take a boat out on the lake near Olivia's house with some fishing sonar that she'd bought years earlier thinking someday it might come in handy to find missing people.
现在，在几十起案件中，有时她独自一人，有时与执法部门合作。莉莎发挥了她在那起初次案件中所展现出的同样的坚韧和机智。例如，2017 年，一名叫奥利维亚·孤熊（Olivia Lone Bear）的女子在莉莎的保留地上失踪时，全国范围内都在寻找她。但莉莎的理论是，她可能离家不远，即她最后被看到的地方。有一天，她决定带着几年前买的鱼类声纳划船去奥利维亚家附近的湖上，当时她想这玩意儿以后找失踪人口可能会派上用场。
She just launched the boat. And yeah, within about 10 minutes, her younger relative spotted some shape on the fishing sonar and said, hey, Auntie, what's that? And Lissa looked at it, and it was a truck. And Olivia was inside.
她刚把船下水。是的，大约 10 分钟内，她年轻的亲戚就在声纳上发现了一个形状，说，嘿，阿姨，那是什么？莉莎看了一眼，那是一辆卡车。奥利维亚就在里面。
Months before this, Lissa and Olivia's family had tried to convince law enforcement authorities to look in that lake.
在这几个月前，莉莎和奥利维亚的家人曾试图说服执法部门去那个湖里搜寻。
Lots of Native Americans go missing and are never found. We don't even have good statistics on this, because the cases are so underreported and poorly tracked. A big part of the problem? There are these federal laws that limit who can investigate cases and how they can investigate them on reservations, which leads to a jurisdictional tangle. And it's often not clear which law enforcement agency is supposed to take a case.
许多美洲原住民失踪后就再也没有被找到。我们甚至连相关的准确统计数据都没有，因为这些案件的报告率极低，且追踪记录不完善。问题的主要原因是什么？联邦法律限制了谁有权在保留地上调查案件以及如何调查，这导致了管辖权的纠缠。而且通常不清楚哪个执法机构应该接手案件。
If you don't know if they disappeared from on a reservation or off a reservation, it's really hard to say whose responsibility that case is.
如果你不知道他们是从保留地内还是保留地外失踪的，就很难说这案子归谁管。
On the reservation, tribal police or the federal authorities. Off the reservation, city, or county, or state police.
在保留地上，是部落警察或联邦当局。在保留地外，是城市、县或州警察。
But because it's so unclear, those cases can become a lot lower priority, or those cases can be ignored by all jurisdictions. And that's where Lissa Yellow Bird comes in. She searches for the people who slip through these jurisdictional cracks.
但由于界限不清，这些案件往往被降低优先级，或者被所有司法管辖区忽略。而这正是莉莎·黄鸟发挥作用的地方。她寻找那些在管辖权缝隙中失踪的人。
So what's the story you're about to tell?
那么你今天要讲的故事是什么？
So in 2016, Lissa's own niece went missing. And this was the first time that she went searching for someone who wasn't a stranger. She just never expected that it would happen to her own relative.
2016 年，莉莎自己的侄女失踪了。这是她第一次去寻找一个不是陌生人的人。她根本没想到这种事会发生在自己的亲人身上。
But this case is really remarkable for a lot of reasons. For one, she figured it out in just five days. She also recorded all of her conversations, which is something that Lissa does a lot. She saves everything. She photographs everything. She records everything.
但这个案子确实在很多方面都很引人注目。首先，她在短短五天内就查明了真相。她还录下了所有的谈话，这是莉莎常做的事情。她保存一切。她拍摄一切。她记录一切。
And Lissa gave me these phone calls that she'd recorded over the course of these five days. And they were just incredible because they really showed how she was able to break this case open in a minute-by-minute way.
莉莎把她在五天里录下的电话录音给了我。它们简直太不可思议了，因为它们真实地展现了她是如何一步步破获这个案子的。
Sierra says another thing about this case-- she and Lissa talked for hours all the time about everything. But after those five days when Lissa was working this case--
塞拉说关于这个案子还有一点——她和莉莎经常一聊就是好几个小时，无所不谈。但在莉莎处理这个案子的那五天之后——
She just kind of went quiet about it. We didn't talk about it for years, which is really unusual because Lissa is always talking about her cases. She just never talked about this case again, though. And I knew that-- I knew because she was so quiet about it, and I knew also because it was her own relative that it had affected her in a way that no other case had.
她就对这事保持沉默了。我们有好几年没提过这件事，这很不寻常，因为莉莎总是会谈论她的案子。但她再也没有谈起过这个案子。我知道——我知道是因为她对此太安静了，而且我也知道这是她自己的亲戚，这件事对她的影响与以往任何案子都不同。
But I didn't really know why, entirely. I thought there was something else going on. And three years passed, and that was when she finally said, OK, yeah, I'm ready to talk about it. She wanted to talk about it.
但我并不完全了解原因。我想还有其他隐情。三年过去了，那是她终于说，好吧，是的，我准备好谈谈它了。她想聊聊这件事。
Sierra suggested doing a story, and Lissa said yes. She wanted people to hear it. And that is what we're bringing you today. We listen in on this exceptional investigator, Lissa Yellow Bird. Those phone calls, they are really amazing. She just knows how to read people and how to pull information out of them that other people cannot get. And we hear her crack this case in five very intense days.
塞拉建议写个报道，莉莎答应了。她想让人们听到它。这就是我们今天带来的内容。我们来听听这位杰出的调查员莉莎·黄鸟的故事。那些电话录音真的非常惊人。她懂得如何读懂人心，如何从他们口中挖出别人无法获得的信息。我们将会听到她在短短五天内如何极其紧张地破获此案。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And before we get to this story, a heads up. This story mentions violence, including sexual violence. Here's Sierra Crane Murdoch.
这里是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《这就是美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。在开始这个故事之前，先提个醒。这个故事提到了暴力，包括性暴力。下面是塞拉·克兰·默多克。
The last time I saw Lissa, we were at her grandma's house on the Fort Berthold Indian Reservation. This was in February. Her mom had called her over to find their missing cat, not something Lissa usually searches for, but she drove over right away in her hot pink pajamas.
我最后一次见到莉莎是在她奶奶家，位于伯特霍尔德堡印第安保留地（Fort Berthold Indian Reservation）。那是在二月。她妈妈叫她过去找他们失踪的猫，这不是莉莎通常会找的东西，但她穿着粉红色的睡衣就直接开车过来了。
And while everyone's eating breakfast, Lissa walks to the window, stares out with binoculars. Lissa thinks some coyotes got the cat. A few days earlier, her mom bought a hunting rifle, and everyone's cracking up at the idea of Lissa's mom, a retired professor who doesn't like to be outside and who's never had a gun, taking to the porch with her rifle. Lissa asks her nephew, Mercury, to teach her mom how to use it.
当大家在吃早餐时，莉莎走到窗前，用望远镜向外盯着看。莉莎认为是有土狼抓了那只猫。几天前，她妈妈买了一把猎枪，大家都在笑话莉莎的妈妈——一个不喜欢出门且从未碰过枪的退休教授，居然拿着猎枪站在门廊上。莉莎让她的侄子默丘里（Mercury）教她妈妈怎么用枪。
Yeah, it's a scary situation, Mercury. We need your help.
是啊，情况很糟糕，默丘里。我们需要你的帮助。
Lissa goes to the bedroom to get the rifle. She comes back holding a guitar case and hands it to Mercury.
莉莎去卧室拿枪。她回来时手里拿着一个吉他盒，递给了默丘里。
This is perfect.
这太完美了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I wasn't even paying attention. It's like, oh. [LAUGHS]
我当时甚至没注意。我在想，哦。[笑声]
I picked it up by the neck, and I thought it was a barrel and stuff. It was a Fender guitar.
我拎着琴颈，还以为那是枪管什么的。那是一把芬达吉他。
Sing some songs to those coyotes. [LAUGHS] Ooh-- you'll be out there with the chair, just singing away.
给那些土狼唱几首歌吧。[笑声] 噢——你得坐在外面，一直唱下去。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
My bad. OK, everybody got the laugh of the day.
我的错。好了，大家都笑够了吧。
The Yellow Birds are really close. At any time, you'll find four generations of them just hanging out at Lissa's grandma's house for days on end. And it was at this house-- everyone eating, laughing, watching television-- where they last saw Lissa's niece, Carla Yellow Bird, before she went missing. That was in August of 2016.
黄鸟一家非常亲密。任何时候你都能发现四代人聚在莉莎奶奶家一住就是好几天。就是在那个房子里——大家吃着、笑着、看着电视——他们最后一次见到了莉莎的侄女卡拉·黄鸟（Carla Yellow Bird），就在她失踪之前。那是在 2016 年 8 月。
At first, they weren't that worried. Carla didn't live with the Yellow Birds. She lived about two hours away off the reservation, but she was always stopping by, sometimes stayed the night. She was 27, had lots of energy, confident. She'd walk into her family's house, plug her iPhone into their speakers, and start jamming hip hop.
起初，他们并没有那么担心。卡拉不住在黄鸟家。她住在大约两小时车程外的保留地之外，但她经常顺路过来，有时会留宿。她 27 岁，精力充沛，自信开朗。她会走进家人的房子，把 iPhone 插到音响上，开始放嘻哈音乐。
And it wasn't unusual for Carla to take off for a few days, not answer when they called. When she stopped coming around, her family told Lissa, don't worry.
卡拉离家几天、不接电话也不是什么罕见的事。当她不再出现时，家人告诉莉莎，别担心。
We were like, oh, she's just out doing her thing, or she's probably doing something she shouldn't be. So, she'll come out.
我们当时想，哦，她只是在忙自己的事，或者可能在做些不该做的事。所以，她会回来的。
Lissa was starting to worry though. Carla was the daughter of one of Lissa's favorite relatives, Uncle Chucky. He died a few years earlier. One of the last things he'd asked Lissa was to look out for Carla.
不过莉莎开始担心了。卡拉是莉莎最喜欢的亲戚之一——查基叔叔（Uncle Chucky）的女儿。他几年前去世了。他临终前问莉莎的最后一件事之一就是照顾好卡拉。
Then one morning, Lissa had a dream about Chucky. It wasn't long. He just kind of appeared, and he said, you need to go get Carla now. Lissa called her family and found out the night before they'd asked a holy woman to come to the house and pray for Carla. They hadn't wanted to tell Lissa.
然后有一天早上，莉莎做了一个关于查基的梦。梦境很短。他出现了，他说，你现在得去把卡拉找回来。莉莎给家人打了电话，发现前一天晚上他们请了一位圣女来家里为卡拉祈祷。他们本来不想告诉莉莎。
And I was like, what do you mean you had a ceremony? So if you guys didn't think anything was wrong, what would you be having a ceremony for? And I said, look, somebody needs to come clean with me and tell me what the hell is really going on.
我说，你们说的举行仪式是什么意思？如果你们认为没事，那你们为什么还要举行仪式？我说，听着，得有人跟我说实话，到底发生了什么鬼事。
Her mom told her they actually were really worried. At this point, no one had heard from Carla in weeks.
她妈妈告诉她，他们其实真的很担心。此时，已经几周没有人卡拉的消息了。
And I said, why did you guys lie to me? Well, we didn't lie, we just don't want you to put all this stuff out on social media, and we know that's probably what will happen.
我说，你们为什么要骗我？噢，我们没骗你，只是不想让你把这些事发到社交媒体上，我们知道那很可能会发生。
Lissa's family told her they didn't want it on social media, out of protectiveness for Carla. Carla had been in some legal trouble. She was addicted to meth. They didn't want to make things harder for her. Lissa thought maybe they were also embarrassed. In the Yellow Bird family are professors, anthropologists, social workers, all very aware of the stereotypes used to shame native communities.
莉莎的家人告诉她，他们不想让这件事上社交媒体，是为了保护卡拉。卡拉曾惹上过法律纠纷。她对冰毒上瘾。他们不想让她的处境变得更难。莉莎想也许他们也感到尴尬。在黄鸟家族里，有教授、人类学家、社会工作者，大家都非常清楚用来羞辱原住民社区的刻板印象。
Being drunken, being filthy, being all these labels that they give us that, when something of that nature takes over one of our family members, the last thing we want to admit is that it's hit us. I think what it boils down to is trying to keep a good reputation. So I think that played a major role of shame.
醉醺醺、肮脏，这些被贴在我们身上的标签，当类似的事情发生在我们家庭成员身上时，我们最不愿承认的就是它降临到了我们头上。我想这归根结底是在努力维护良好的名声。所以我认为羞耻感在其中起了很大作用。
Lissa's seen this firsthand with how the family treated her. She was addicted to meth, spent three years in prison for dealing. For a while, her family avoided her. Even now, Lissa's been sober 15 years, and they don't like to talk about it. Lissa's mom doesn't even use the word "prison." She calls it "Lissa's other college."
莉莎亲眼目睹了家人是如何对待她的。她曾沉迷于冰毒，因贩毒在监狱里待了三年。有一段时间，她的家人躲着她。即使现在，莉莎已经戒毒 15 年了，他们还是不喜欢谈论这个。莉莎的妈妈甚至不使用“监狱”这个词。她称之为“莉莎的另一所大学”。
Lissa couldn't disagree more with this attitude. She believes that when someone goes missing, that's the worst possible time to hide the facts. Often the things someone is trying to cover up can be part of what led them to go missing in the first place.
莉莎完全不同意这种态度。她认为，当有人失踪时，那是隐藏事实的最坏时机。通常一个人试图掩盖的事情，可能就是导致他们失踪的原因。
Lissa called Carla's mom, Loretta. Loretta lived a few hours away on another reservation, and the Yellow Birds didn't know her very well. Carla's parents weren't together long. Loretta told Lissa she'd reported Carla missing a few weeks earlier. Lissa offered to help find Carla, and Loretta said yes.
莉莎给卡拉的妈妈洛蕾塔（Loretta）打了电话。洛蕾塔住在几个小时车程外的另一个保留地上，黄鸟一家不太了解她。卡拉的父母在一起的时间不长。洛蕾塔告诉莉莎，她几周前已经报过案了。莉莎主动提出帮忙寻找卡拉，洛蕾塔答应了。
So Lissa got to work. One of the first people she called was the officer responsible for the case, April Jose, a detective for the city of Mandan, where Carla lived. April said she'd learned that in the days before Carla disappeared, Carla was on the Fort Berthold Reservation, and she might have gone to a second reservation, called Spirit Lake. But April didn't have jurisdiction on reservations. She was a city cop.
于是莉莎开始行动。她打给的第一个人是负责此案的警官——曼丹市（Mandan）的侦探阿普里尔·何塞（April Jose），卡拉住在那里。阿普里尔说，她了解到在卡拉失踪前几天，卡拉在伯特霍尔德堡保留地上，她可能去了第二个保留地，叫“灵魂湖”（Spirit Lake）。但阿普里尔在保留地上没有管辖权。她只是一名城市警察。
This is another part of the jurisdictional tangle in these cases. April was trying to follow every lead, but she could only go so far. To interview suspects on the reservation, she needed the cooperation of law enforcement there. It's part of the Bureau of Indian Affairs. But no one was calling her back.
这是这些案件中管辖权纠缠的另一个部分。阿普里尔试图跟进每一条线索，但她能做的非常有限。为了在保留地上讯问嫌疑人，她需要当地执法部门的配合。这属于印第安事务局（Bureau of Indian Affairs）的一部分。但没有人回她的电话。
She did tell me this spans five states and three reservations. My hands are tied. And I said, mine aren't. I'll go wherever. This is my niece.
她确实告诉我这涉及五个州和三个保留地。我束手无策。我说，我不会。我会去任何地方。这是我的侄女。
So Lissa did exactly the thing her family didn't want her to do. She opened Facebook and wrote, "Carla Yellow Bird has been missing, and I want to know any and all info related to her disappearance before I take this to the next level." People in the broader native community know Lissa, the work she does. When she puts something on Facebook, people respond, give her leads they might be more cautious about giving police. She started getting calls right away, and she learned Carla was last seen driving around with two men on the Spirit Lake Indian Reservation.
所以莉莎做了她家人不希望她做的事。她打开 Facebook 写道：“卡拉·黄鸟失踪了，在进入下一阶段之前，我想要知道任何与她失踪有关的信息。”更广泛的原住民社区的人们认识莉莎，了解她所做的工作。当她在 Facebook 上发布消息时，人们会回应，提供给她的线索可能比给警察的要谨慎。她很快就开始接到电话，并得知卡拉最后一次露面是和两个男人一起开车，在灵魂湖印第安保留地上。
And they just describe it was an older car. It was smaller. It had two different kinds of paint, maybe a replacement front quarter panel. And it had plastic on one window.
他们描述那是一辆旧车。车身较小。它有两种不同的车漆，也许前四分之一面板换过。一个窗户上还贴着塑料布。
So when I put that out there, people from Spirit Lake, people from Bismarck were like, hey, we saw that car. We saw these people. We know Carla. That car belongs to Suna Guy's father.
所以我把消息发出去后，来自灵魂湖和俾斯麦（Bismarck）的人说，嘿，我们见过那辆车。我们见过这些人。我们认识卡拉。那辆车属于苏纳·盖（Suna Guy）的父亲。
Suna Guy, she hears this name a few times. He's a member of the Spirit Lake Tribe. So Lissa posts again on Facebook, says her niece was last seen with Suna Guy, gives his full name. And within a few hours, she gets a call from a blocked number.
苏纳·盖，她听过几次这个名字。他是灵魂湖部落的一员。于是莉莎再次在 Facebook 上发帖，说她的侄女最后一次出现是和苏纳·盖在一起，并给出了他的全名。几个小时内，她就接到了一个匿名电话。
Why is my name being put in stuff when I don't even know what's going on?
为什么要把我的名字扯进来，我甚至都不知道发生了什么？
OK, that's fine. I appreciate that.
好，没问题。我理解。
It's Suna.
我是苏纳。
I'm not a bad guy, you know what I mean? If there's a way I can help anybody, I try. I mean-- what's your name again? I don't even know your name, but I'm calling you.
我不是坏人，你明白吗？如果有什么我能帮上忙的，我会试着帮忙。我是说——你叫什么名字？我甚至不知道你的名字，但我打了电话。
Here, I'll spell it for you, OK?
来，我给你拼一下，好吗？
Yeah.
好的。
It's L-I-S-S-A.
是 L-I-S-S-A。
Lisa? Lissa?
Lisa？Lissa？
Lissa.
Lissa。
Say it 16 times, and you won't forget it.
说 16 遍，你就不会忘了。
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑声] 是啊。
So do you have any other insight into what happened to Carla?
那你对卡拉身上发生了什么还有什么了解吗？
Do I? No, I don't. I'm just trying to clear up the air where-- hey, I made contact with you guys. I'm just letting you guys know only what I know. That's all I know.
我吗？没有，我没有。我只是想澄清一下——嘿，我联系你们了。我只是把我知道的情况告诉你们。我只知道这些。
Hmm. Well, your efforts are duly noted.
嗯。那么，你的努力会得到应有的认可。
Mm-hm.
嗯。
There are long stretches where Lissa doesn't say anything, just lets Suna fill the silence. Lissa sounds sort of unimpressed, which is tactical.
莉莎有很长一段时间没说话，只是让苏纳填补沉默。莉莎听起来有些不为所动，这是战术。
So do you want to give me your phone number? Or do you feel kind of paranoid about that?
那你愿意给我你的电话号码吗？还是说你对这事有点多疑？
Why would I be paranoid? What I'm just saying-- does all that mean--
我为什么要多疑？我只是说——那意味着什么——
Well, I don't know. I'm just saying, you know? I understand where you're coming from.
嗯，我不知道。我只是随口一说，你知道吗？我理解你的处境。
You know what? Put it like this. Only certain people have my phone number.
你知道吗？这样说吧。只有特定的人才有我的电话号码。
OK, so you don't want to give it to me then? Is that what you're saying?
好吧，所以你是不想给我了？你是这个意思吗？
Yeah, because you know what-- [SCOFFS]
是的，因为你知道——[嗤之以鼻]
OK.
好吧。
You make me feel like I've got something hiding or something. Maybe I did-- I mean, I feel I'm doing something right by contacting you and letting you know.
你让我觉得我有什么隐瞒似的。也许我——我是说，我觉得我主动联系你并告诉你这些，是在做正确的事。
Well, I'm not-- like I said, I appreciate it. I'm not trying to give you that feeling. I'm not trying to give you that feeling at all.
嗯，我不是——像我说的，我很感激。我一点也不想给你那种感觉。
You know what I mean?
你明白我的意思吗？
What I'm trying to do is I'm trying to find out where my niece is at.
我想要做的是找到我侄女在哪。
Yeah, I understand. And like I said I mean, if I knew more than what I only know-- I'm being honest to got truth-- I would give you all the information I do know-- I would know, you know what I mean?
是啊，我理解。就像我说的，如果我知道的比我目前了解的更多——我发誓这是实话——我会把我知道的一切信息都给你的——我会知道的，你明白吗？
Lissa spends a lot of this conversation trying to get Suna to give her his number. I should say Lissa is really good at talking on the phone. She told me once, you know me, I'll keep a dumbass on the phone forever.
莉莎在这段谈话中花了很多时间想让苏纳给她号码。我应该说莉莎真的非常擅长打电话。她曾经对我说过，你了解我的，我可以和一个蠢货在电话上聊个没完。
Yeah, I try to help people the best I can.
是啊，我尽我所能帮助别人。
Yeah, well, I sure could use your help finding my niece.
是啊，我真的很需要你的帮助来找到我侄女。
I mean, most definitely. Like I say, I mean, sorry, I'm not trying to be an asshole or nothing, but I mean, if I come across and hear anything, I'll contact you, you know what I mean?
当然，绝对的。就像我说的，抱歉，我不是想当混蛋什么的，但如果我遇到了什么或者听到了什么，我会联系你的，你明白吗？
Yep. Well, it's the only way we're going to get to the bottom of things, OK? So you'll call me in the morning then?
好吧。那这是我们弄清真相的唯一办法，好吗？所以你明天早上会打给我？
Yeah. Like I say, I mean, I don't got nothing to hide. Other than that, I got my kids up here. I got to get them ready for bed here. My wife gets off work here pretty soon, so--
会的。就像我说的，我没什么好隐瞒的。除此之外，我还要照顾我的孩子们。我得准备让他们睡觉。我妻子很快就下班了，所以——
All right.
好吧。
All right. Have a good night.
好了。晚安。
OK. Thank you.
好的。谢谢。
Yeah, bye.
再见。
Bye. Mother fuck.
再见。妈的。
Lissa thinks he's lying. Suna knows something. The next day, Lissa tracked down the other guy people had seen in the car with Suna and Carla the night she disappeared. He was a friend of Carla's, named Jason. Lissa got him on the phone.
莉莎认为他在撒谎。苏纳一定知道些什么。第二天，莉莎找到了在卡拉失踪那天晚上和苏纳及卡拉在一起的另一个男人。他是卡拉的朋友，叫杰森（Jason）。莉莎拨通了他的电话。
Don't know if she's OK or where she's at.
我不知道她是否平安，或者她在哪里。
Jason said Carla had drugs she wanted to sell in Spirit Lake, so Suna had offered to pick her up a few hours away and drive her and Jason back to the reservation. When they got there, Jason said Suna ditched him and took off with Carla and some other guys, guys who are known as scary, violent. Then hours later, Jason ran into them again, but Carla wasn't with them.
杰森说卡拉想在灵魂湖卖药，所以苏纳提议几个小时前去接她，带她和杰森回保留地。当他们到达那里时，杰森说苏纳甩了他，带着卡拉和其他几个人走了，那些人以可怕、暴力著称。几小时后，杰森又碰到了他们，但卡拉不在其中。
You know what? I'm thinking they killed her.
你知道吗？我在想他们杀了她。
Knowing Suna, he--
了解苏纳的话，他——
He'd kill her.
他会杀了她的。
Lissa was starting to feel sure that Carla was dead. At the same time, she was gathering leads. She was also talking almost every day with April Jose, the detective in Mandan. April had gotten a hold of Carla's phone records, bank account, and seen no activity.
莉莎开始确信卡拉已经死了。与此同时，她在收集线索。她也几乎每天都和曼丹市的侦探阿普里尔·何塞通话。阿普里尔查到了卡拉的电话记录和银行账户，显示没有任何活动。
Lissa decides she needs to apply more pressure, so she goes on Facebook again, blasts Suna's name in another public post. She writes, "I have been given information that Carla was last seen riding with Suna Guy. Please contact me by private message. Your confidentiality is assured." And then the phone rings.
莉莎决定施加更大的压力，所以她再次上了 Facebook，在另一个公开帖子里痛斥苏纳的名字。她写道：“我得到信息说卡拉最后一次露面是和苏纳·盖在一起。请私信联系我。保证为你保密。”接着电话响了。
Hello. Is this Lisa? Lissa?
你好。是 Lisa 吗？Lissa？
It's Suna.
我是苏纳。
Remember what I said? If you say it 16 times, you'll remember it?
记得我说过的话吗？如果你说 16 遍，你会记住它的？
Yeah. Well, what is this that you're posting on Facebook that your niece was last seen with me and my girlfriend?
是的。那你在 Facebook 上发帖说你侄女最后一次露面是和我及我女朋友在一起，这是怎么回事？
Oh, I didn't say your girlfriend. I didn't say your girlfriend. You need to reread the post.
哦，我没说你女朋友。我没说你女朋友。你需要重读那个帖子。
Well--
好吧——
You need to get honest with me, because I'm done playing.
你需要跟我说实话，因为我没空陪你玩了。
Well, I been only honest with you. I don't know what you want me to make anything else up more, I mean, because I'm not making nothing up.
嗯，我一直对你很诚实。我不知道你还想让我编造什么，我是说，我什么都没编造。
Well, from what I understand, Carla's gone. And you know what? Oh, well, she's gone. There's nothing I can do about that, but I want to know where her fucking body is. I'm done playing this shit.
嗯，据我所知，卡拉已经没了。你知道吗？好吧，她没了。我无能为力，但我想要知道她那该死的尸体在哪里。我不想再玩这套把戏了。
Do you know what? You're making me feel like I got to say something. I don't know.
你知道吗？你让我觉得我非得说点什么。我不知道。
You know what? You know what, Suna?
你知道吗？你知道吗，苏纳？
Huh?
啊？
Nobody cares about how you feel. I just told you I want my niece's body back. Somebody better fucking come up. What is it going to take, some cash so y'all can go get high again?
没人关心你的感受。我刚才告诉你了，我想要回我侄女的尸体。最好有人给老娘站出来。到底要什么？一些现金好让你们再去吸毒吗？
Who's getting high?
谁在吸毒？
You're getting high. Don't play me.
你在吸毒。别糊弄我。
[INAUDIBLE]
[听不清]
Don't play me. You have a reputation out there. You have a reputation.
别糊弄我。你在外面名声很臭。你有前科的。
Of what?
什么前科？
I'm not going to explain that to you. You know it better than I do. I'm just saying--
我没必要向你解释。你比我清楚。我只是说——
You know what?
你知道吗？
I'm just saying, what's it going to cost me, Suna? Because that's what you're all about, right?
我只是在说，这要花我多少钱，苏纳？因为这正是你关心的，对吧？
Huh? What?
啊？什么？
Right? That you want to get high? I'll give you five grand to get your fucking high on. Maybe you'll take yourself out with that, but oh, well. I want my niece's body. How about that?
对吧？你想要去吸毒？我可以给你五千块钱让你去吸个够。也许你会因为那个把自己搞死，但也无所谓。我想要我侄女的尸体。这个提议怎么样？
You know what?
你知道吗？
I'm being fucking real with you.
我在跟你说真的。
You're asking somebody to--
你是在要求某人——
I'm being way fucking real with you. And you know what? I tell you, I'm a fucking mess to be reckoned with when I'm fucking mad. And now I'm getting fucking mad.
我在跟你说他妈的真的。你知道吗？我告诉你，我发起火来是个狠角色。我现在正火大着呢。
I don't even know what anybody's even talking about.
我根本不知道谁在说什么。
So what's up, Suna? Let's get honest here. If you need to come up with a defense, whatever, but I want to know where her body's at, plain and simple.
所以怎么说，苏纳？坦诚点吧。如果你需要找个借口什么的，但我只想知道她的尸体在哪，简单明了。
Well, you know what? I made the initiative to call you and tell you what only I know.
好吧，你知道吗？我主动联系你告诉了你我唯一知道的事。
You know what?
你知道吗？
And that's all I know.
我只知道这些。
You think I haven't dealt with your kind of people before? I have. I'll come get her personally, myself, if I have to, but I want to know. If you have any fucking faith in anything in your life, just fucking tell me where her body's at.
你以为我没处理过你们这种人吗？我处理过。如果我必须的话，我会亲自去把她带回来，但我必须知道。如果你的人生中还有哪怕一点点信仰，就他妈告诉我现在尸体在哪。
What do you want me to say to you? What do you want me to say to you? What do you want me to--
你想让我说什么？你想让我说什么？你想让我——
The truth. How about let's try for the truth.
真话。我们试着讲真话吧。
I've been telling you the truth.
我一直在告诉你真话。
Suna, you know what? When you want to get honest, you want to get fucking real, and you want to try and save your own ass, call me back. But until then, I'm fucking done, OK?
苏纳，你知道吗？什么时候你想诚实了，想来点实在的，想救你自己的命了，再打给我。在那之前，老娘没空理你了，好吗？
OK then. That's fine.
好吧。那随你便。
All right, cool.
行，酷。
Suna still hasn't told her anything. But this time, Lissa doesn't try to keep him on the phone. She hangs up on him, the guy whose number she doesn't have, the guy she suspects murdered her niece. Lissa's anger here, that's not a tactic. She's enraged. What's crazy to me is that Suna stays on the phone and takes it, and then unprompted decides to call her back, just 10 hours later.
苏纳还是什么都没告诉她。但这一次，莉莎没再试着把他留在电话线上。她挂了他的电话，这个连电话号码都没有的男人，这个她怀疑谋杀了她侄女的男人。莉莎此时的愤怒，那不是战术。她是真的被激怒了。让我觉得疯狂的是，苏纳居然一直在线上听着，然后主动决定在 10 小时后给她回拨了电话。
I don't even know who Carla is, I said.
我说过，我甚至不知道卡拉是谁。
But you do know who Carla is.
但你确实知道卡拉是谁。
No, I don't. I don't know who Carla is. I didn't even speak with Carla.
不，我不知道。我不知道卡拉是谁。我甚至没跟卡拉说过话。
She's got all this dope on her, and you didn't even know who she was. Please.
她身上带着那么多毒品，你居然不知道她是谁。别扯了。
I didn't even know what kind of dope or how much dope she had on--
我甚至都不知道她带了什么毒品或者有多少——
Suna, you're insulting my intelligence.
苏纳，你在侮辱我的智商。
Do you know what? I will get my name cleared. I'm going to speak with the cops, with an attorney. Anything further that goes on with my name, I could press slander and harassment onto it.
你知道吗？我会洗清我的名声。我会和警察、律师谈谈。如果我的名字再被这样消费，我可以起诉诽谤和骚扰。
Do it. I hope that's not a threat, because I'm ready.
去告吧。希望那不是威胁，因为我已经准备好了。
It's not a threat. I'm just telling you--
那不是威胁。我只是告诉你——
OK. Well, then watch your mouth.
好。那管住你的嘴。
I'll be sharing with you what's being shared with me, you know what I mean?
我会和你分享别人分享给我的东西，你明白吗？
I'm being real with you. I got enough shit on you right now, OK?
我在跟你说真的。我现在手里已经握着足够收拾你的把柄了，好吗？
On me?
收拾我？
I got enough shit on you right now, and that's all I'm going to say, OK?
我现在手里有足够的把柄，这就是我要说的全部，好吗？
I know you were mad earlier, and I'm not trying to piss you off.
我知道你之前很生气，我不是想激怒你。
It's going to take me a minute to get my fucking ducks in a row. You go ahead and try and bring slander, because I've had bigger fish try to bring me down, people with multi-millions of dollars.
我得花点时间收拾我的残局。你尽管去告我诽谤吧，因为我遇到过更厉害的角色想搞垮我，那些有数百万资产的人。
I understand.
我明白。
And you know what? Good fucking luck.
你知道吗？祝你好运。
Carla and Lissa had some things in common. There are obvious things. They both had addictions. They were both mothers. They really loved their kids. But because of their addictions, they'd had their kids taken away from them for stretches of time. They knew how awful that felt.
卡拉和莉莎有一些共同点。有很明显的地方。她们都有瘾。她们都是母亲。她们真的很爱孩子。但由于她们的毒瘾，她们的孩子曾一度被带走。她们知道那种感觉有多糟糕。
It was a lot for her. I'm sure I wasn't the favorite auntie, because I was worried. I'd say-- if she was doing wrong, I could tell just by the way our first eye contact was. And she'd be like, jeez, auntie, you know? Not every time I'm here is bad.
这对她来说太多了。我肯定我不是她最喜欢的阿姨，因为我总是很担心。我会说——如果她做了坏事，从我们第一次对视我就能看出来。她会说，天哪，阿姨，你知道吗？不是每次我来都是坏事。
Lissa says Carla was a really cute kid-- kind of shy, giddy. But as Carla got older, Lissa would get on her case. Carla was known to take your stuff, little things. Like if you left your earrings out, you might later see your relative wearing them. And they'd be like, look at the cute earrings Carla gave me. The last time Lissa saw Carla, they were at their grandma's house. Lissa walked in on Carla raiding the fridge.
莉莎说卡拉小时候真的很可爱——有点害羞，活泼。但随着卡拉长大，莉莎开始盯着她。卡拉出了名的爱拿别人的东西，一些小物件。比如如果你把耳环放外面，你可能会晚点看到你的亲戚戴着它们。他们会说，看卡拉送我的漂亮耳环。莉莎最后一次见卡拉是在奶奶家。莉莎撞见卡拉在翻冰箱。
And all of a sudden, I see this big, gaudy, fake diamond ring. I didn't even see her head, because she had it so far in there trying to get some munchies out. It was like this two-karat-- I don't even think it was a cubic zirconia. And I was like, oh, my god.
突然间，我看到一枚很大、很俗气的假钻戒。我甚至没看到她的头，因为她把头伸得太深在找零食。那大概是两克拉的——我觉得那甚至不是立方氧化锆。我当时就想，天哪。
She heard my voice, and her head popped up. And she was like, oh, here she comes to pick on me again. She's like, what, what? And I went over there, and I literally grabbed that fake gem. And I said, let me see this once.
她听到了我的声音，头一下子弹了出来。她说，哦，她又来找我麻烦了。她说，干嘛，干嘛？我走过去，直接抓住了那颗假宝石。我说，让我看看这玩意儿。
And she took it off, and she was like, oh, my god. I thought you were going to start in on me again. [LAUGHS] She was in better condition that day. I said, I am going to start in on you because of this stupid ring.
她把它摘下来，她说，天哪。我还以为你又要开始教训我了。[笑声] 她那天状态好些。我说，我就要因为这枚愚蠢的戒指教训你。
Lissa told her, damn, Carla, if you're going to steal, at least steal something nice. Still, when Carla needed help, she often called Lissa. And Lissa tried to help her as best she could because of Carla's dad, Chucky. He's a big part of why it's taken Lissa so long to talk about Carla and why it still hurts so much.
莉莎对她说，该死，卡拉，如果你要偷，至少偷点好的。不过，当卡拉需要帮助时，她经常打给莉莎。而莉莎尽她所能去帮助她，都是为了卡拉的父亲查基。他也是莉莎花了这么久才谈起卡拉、以及为何至今依然感到心痛的重要原因。
Let me just tell you what happened. A few years before Carla went missing, Chucky moved in with his mom, Lissa's grandma. Lissa would visit him a lot, spend hours in his bedroom. They'd flip through books together and talk about them. Chucky didn't have as many graduate degrees as others in his family, but everyone said he was the smartest Yellow Bird.
让我告诉你发生了什么。在卡拉失踪前几年，查基搬去和他妈妈、也就是莉莎的奶奶住了。莉莎常去看他，在他的卧室待上几个小时。他们一起翻书讨论。查基没有像家里其他人那样的高学历，但大家都说他是黄鸟家最聪明的人。
It made Lissa feel good to keep up with him. She liked proving to herself and to Chucky that she hadn't totally fried her brain with drugs. They spent lots of time debating this massive book he kept by his bed, The Code of Federal Regulations, Title 25. It spells out how the US government is supposed to fulfill its obligations to tribes in exchange for taking their land, how it's supposed to always act in their best interest, for their well-being, obligations the government has ignored in all kinds of ways both Lissa and Chucky witnessed themselves.
能跟上他的节奏让莉莎感觉很好。她喜欢向自己和查基证明，她没有因为毒品彻底烧坏脑子。他们花了很多时间争论他床头放着的一本巨著，《美国联邦法规》第 25 卷。它明确规定了美国政府如何履行对部落的义务以换取他们的土地，它应该如何永远为他们的利益着想，为了他们的福祉——这些义务被政府以各种方式无视，而莉莎和查基都亲眼目睹了这些。
Chucky was four years old during a major event in their tribe. The US government built a dam, flooded out most of the reservation, forced everyone, including the Yellow Birds, to relocate. They were farmers, self-sufficient, but the land the government moved them to was unfarmable. There was huge unemployment. A lot of people left the reservation for cities. Chucky and most of his generation were sent away to boarding schools where a lot of them were abused.
当他们的部落发生一件大事时，查基才四岁。美国政府建了一座大坝，淹没了保留地的大部分土地，强迫所有人，包括黄鸟家族，搬迁。他们本来是农民，自给自足，但政府搬迁去的土地根本无法耕种。失业率极高。许多人离开保留地去了城市。查基和他那一代的大多数人被送往寄宿学校，许多人在那里遭受了虐待。
In his room, Chucky also had stacks of articles about an emerging science called epigenetics that's shown how traumatic stress can change the way a person's genes behave and how those changes can affect your kids' genes, make it likelier that they develop illnesses, like depression or PTSD. Chucky put into words a pattern Lissa had observed her whole life, that she and the people she would later help had been delivered into a system where they had no chance, a system that kept taking from them, until they died. And their bodies are dragged behind bushes or left to drift at the bottoms of rivers and lakes. And few people bother to look for them, to fish them out.
在房间里，查基还有一堆关于一门新兴科学——表观遗传学——的文章，它显示创伤性压力如何改变一个人的基因表现方式，以及这些变化如何影响你孩子的基因，使他们更有可能患上抑郁症或创伤后应激障碍等疾病。查基用言语道出了莉莎一生观察到的模式，即她和她后来帮助过的人们被送进了一个他们毫无机会的系统，一个不断从他们身上索取的系统，直到他们死去。他们的身体被拖进灌木丛，或者任其漂流在河流和湖泊的底部。几乎没人费心去寻找他们，把他们捞上来。
Chucky himself wasn't doing so well. He was an alcoholic. He was in his early 60s, and he had cirrhosis.
查基自己的状况也不太好。他是个酒鬼。他六十出头，患有肝硬化。
One night when Chucky was drinking, he got violent, and his mom kicked him out of the house. Lissa called him and told him to come to Fargo where she was living. She didn't think he'd come. But then he called her one night from a Fargo hotel. He wouldn't tell her which one.
有一天晚上查基喝酒时变得暴躁，他妈妈把他赶出了家门。莉莎打电话叫他来她居住的法戈（Fargo）。她没想过他会来。但后来有一天晚上他从法戈的一家酒店打给她。他不肯告诉她是哪一家。
He was like, I've been drinking. And I know you're in sobriety, I know you're doing well, so I don't want to bring that to your house. And I was like, well, that don't make no sense, because I told you if you want to die by the bottle that's fine with me, but I just want to be near you. I don't want you out on the streets somewhere freezing to death, or any weird stuff going on. So if you could just get your butt over here, that would be great. And he's like, no, I got a room. I'll be good for tonight. And tomorrow, I'll come over.
他说，我一直在喝酒。我知道你在戒酒，我知道你过得很好，所以我不想把这些带到你家。我说，那没意义，因为我告诉过你，如果你想因为酒而死，我无所谓，但我只是想在你身边。我不想让你在街上某个地方冻死，或者发生什么怪事。所以如果你能赶紧过来，那再好不过了。他说，不，我有房间。我今晚会好好的。明天我再过去。
Later that night, Chucky called Lissa again. He said he was going to kill himself. Lissa stayed on the phone with him all night, for seven hours. She kept him on one line. On the other line-- she took her son's phone-- dialed the police. She called every hotel in the city looking for him. Before Lissa could find him, Chucky hung himself. That was the night he asked Lissa to watch out for Carla.
那天晚上晚些时候，查基又给莉莎打了电话。他说他要自杀。莉莎在电话里陪了他一整晚，整整七个小时。她一直守着一条线。在另一条线上——她拿了儿子的电话——拨打了警察局。她打遍了城里所有的酒店找他。在莉莎找到他之前，查基上吊自杀了。那正是他请求莉莎照顾卡拉的那个晚上。
In the three days Lissa was getting all these calls from Suna, she was also trying over and over to reach the one investigator who has the authority to look into crimes on the Spirit Lake Indian Reservation, an investigator with the Bureau of Indian Affairs. Lissa left a ton of messages for him, even asked a tribal councilman to call on her behalf. And finally, after days of this, the investigator returned her calls.
在莉莎接到苏纳那些电话的三天里，她也一次又一次地试图联系那位有权在灵魂湖印第安保留地调查犯罪的调查员，一名隶属印第安事务局的调查员。莉莎给他留了无数信息，甚至请了一位部落议员代表她打电话。最终，在经历了数天之后，那位调查员回了电话。
Hello?
喂？
Hello. Is this Lisa?
喂。是 Lisa 吗？
Lissa, yep.
我是 Lissa。
Yeah. This is the officer from Fort Totton.
是的。我是来自托滕堡（Fort Totton）的警官。
Hello.
喂。
I'm calling about Carla Yellow Bird.
我是关于卡拉·黄鸟的案子。
Yep.
好的。
I'd like to get an update on what's going on.
我想了解一下目前的情况。
He tells Lissa, we know about Suna. We're looking for him, but we can't find him anywhere.
他告诉莉莎，我们知道苏纳。我们正在找他，但哪儿也找不到。
OK. Well, he was driving around all weekend, because I have pictures of him.
好吧。但他整个周末都在开车到处跑，因为我有他的照片。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
You know Suna's called me like three or four times, right?
你知道苏纳给我打了三四次电话了，对吧？
Uh-huh. From what number?
嗯哼。用什么号码？
He blocks it.
他隐藏了号码。
Oh, hmm. Yep.
哦，嗯。是的。
Because I already pretty much know who the culprit is.
因为我已经基本知道罪魁祸首是谁了。
Hmm.
嗯。
And did you know--
你知道吗——
Lissa gives him all the information she has-- who she's talked to, who knows what, where to find them. She seems way ahead of the investigator. This is typical. I've seen Lissa work on dozens of cases. The investigator tells Lissa, don't worry. We got it covered. Then a few hours later--
莉莎给了他她所有的信息——她跟谁谈过，谁知道什么，在哪里能找到他们。她看起来比调查员领先得多。这是典型的。我见过莉莎处理过几十起案件。调查员告诉莉莎，别担心。我们都掌握了。然后几个小时后——
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello, Lissa?
喂，Lissa？
Who's this?
你是谁？
It's Suna. I have no idea why he keeps calling.
我是苏纳。我真不知道他为什么要一直打给我。
You know, I'm just trying to help you.
你知道，我只是想帮你。
You're not trying to help me.
你不是想帮我。
I don't even know. I'm not even-- I don't even know that.
我甚至都不知道。我不是——我甚至都不知道这个。
Suna, quit fucking around, man. If you just come clean, you tell me where my niece's body is at, I will work with you. Because you know what? I know you're a dumb fucker. I know that. And you're probably a career criminal, and that's too bad.
苏纳，别他妈搞了，伙计。如果你坦白从宽，告诉我现在我侄女的尸体在哪，我会配合你的。因为你知道吗？我知道你是个蠢货。我知道那点事。你可能还是个职业罪犯，这太糟糕了。
No, because my parents, they raised me right.
不，因为我父母，他们把我教得很好。
And you know what? I can have pity on you. I can have pity on you, but I want my niece's body.
你知道吗？我可以同情你。我可以同情你，但我想要我侄女的尸体。
Hey, I know that you want to hear something that I don't even know.
嘿，我知道你想要听到一些我根本不知道的东西。
It's just hard to hold my tongue, because I know there's more to it, because I've been doing my research.
但我很难闭嘴，因为我知道这背后还有更多，因为我一直在做调查。
Yeah.
是啊。
It sounds to me like you have a behavior pattern of sexual aggravated assaults.
听起来你有性加重暴力侵害的行为模式。
No.
不。
Actually, yes. Suna raped his child's babysitter and spent 10 years in prison for it. He was 21 at the time. She was 14. One of Lissa's many jobs over the years was as a counselor to sex offenders in a prison.
事实上，是的。苏纳强奸了他孩子保姆，并因此坐了 10 年牢。当时他 21 岁。受害者 14 岁。莉莎这些年做过的众多工作之一就是监狱里的性犯罪咨询师。
I know your kind of people. And you know what? You lie to yourself, till you convince yourself that it's actually true. But you know what I think? I think you haven't ever gone this far before.
我了解你们这类人。你知道吗？你欺骗自己，直到你让自己相信那确实是真的。但我认为呢？我想你以前从来没走过这么远。
But good god, you sure have motive. Because you know what? After spending, what? A 10-year stint? Is that what you did in the big house?
但天哪，你确实有动机。因为你知道吗？在监狱里度过，多少年？这是你在大牢里干的事吗？
Yep.
是的。
Nobody wants to do that shit again, not at your age. And you never really learned anything from that, because they don't give you the proper treatment. They stick you like a little rat in a cage, and they let you sit. And they let you sit, and they let you rot. And your mind goes mushy.
没人想再经历那次烂事，在你这个年纪。你从来没真正从中学到什么，因为他们没给你适当的治疗。他们把你像个小老鼠一样关在笼子里，让你坐在那儿。让你坐在那儿，让你腐烂。你的脑子变得像浆糊一样。
This is the fourth time Suna has called Lissa in three days. It's the middle of the night. She hasn't slept. She's chain smoking cigarettes, downing cup after cup of coffee. Suna starts telling Lissa he's worried. There are some guys he doesn't recognize driving by his house, stalking him. He says they have Texas license plates.
这是苏纳三天内第四次给莉莎打电话了。现在是深夜。她还没睡。她不停地抽烟，一杯接一杯地喝咖啡。苏纳开始告诉莉莎他很担心。有一些他不认识的人开车经过他家，在跟踪他。他说他们挂着德克萨斯州的车牌。
Well, give me the license plate number. I'll look it up for you.
好吧，给我车牌号。我帮你查。
Do you understand what I'm saying? These guys want to try to shoot at me. I can't come and go looking for these guys and just to get a license plate, even though that'd be good information, you know what I mean?
你明白我在说什么吗？这些人想开枪打我。我不能到处去寻找这些人就为了弄个车牌号，即使那是很好的信息，你明白吗？
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
I'm not going to go sneaking up to some people that want to shoot at me, especially--
我才不会潜行到那些想开枪打我的人身边，特别还是在——
[LAUGHING] I got you. I got you. Jeez. I get you. I got your concern. That was dumb.
[笑声] 我明白了。我明白了。天哪。我明白了。我明白了你的顾虑。那真的很蠢。
I mean, I don't know.
我是说，我不知道。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
I got them calling--
他们一直打给我——
I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
抱歉。抱歉。
I called for town PD to even tell them about this, and they ain't even concerned about it, you know what I mean?
我甚至给镇上的警察局打了电话，告诉他们这件事，他们甚至都不关心，你明白吗？
[LAUGHS] I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I didn't-- [LAUGHING] I didn't realize what I just said.
[笑声] 抱歉。抱歉。我没——[笑声] 我没意识到我刚才说了什么。
Yeah?
是吗？
[LAUGHING] [COUGHS]
[笑声][咳嗽]
Lissa laughs like this for a really long time.
莉莎笑了很长很长时间。
But you know what I mean though?
但你明白我的意思吧？
[LAUGHS] Oh, shit. Oh, I'm sorry.
[笑声] 噢，天哪。噢，抱歉。
Because if I got the license plate number, I would give the PD their license plate number over here too, you know what I mean?
因为如果我有车牌号，我也会把车牌号给这边的警察局，你明白吗？
I do. I do. I was out of line. I'm sorry. [LAUGHS] God. [LAUGHING]
我明白。我明白。我刚才失礼了。对不起。[笑声] 天哪。[笑声]
Huh.
哈。
Suna seems totally thrown by this. He tries to laugh too, except it's clear he doesn't understand what's funny. But in Lissa's mind, this was hilarious. The guy she thought murdered her niece, he was calling her for help because he didn't want to get murdered. And then she basically tells him, go get murdered.
苏纳似乎被这彻底搞懵了。他也试图笑，除了显然他并不理解笑点在哪里。但在莉莎心里，这简直太搞笑了。那个她认为谋杀了她侄女的人，竟然给她打电话求助，因为他不想被谋杀。然后她基本等于告诉他，去送死吧。
But you know what, though? I'm sorry, but I understand. I mean, I'm not taking offense or nothing, but I'm glad that you're able to make a laugh out of it, you know what I mean? It's glad to see that you still can laugh, even though-- having a sense of humor, even though this is a serious matter, you know what I mean?
但你知道吗？抱歉，但我理解。我是说，我没觉得被冒犯什么的，但我很高兴你能从中找到笑点，你明白吗？很高兴看到你依然能笑出来，即使——即使事情很严重，你明白吗？
Yeah, I know that.
是啊，我知道。
And all that.
还有这一切。
I was out of line. I'm sorry. [LAUGHING] Go get the plate number. Oh, shit. Oh, I must be getting tired. I'm sorry.
我刚才失礼了。对不起。[笑声] 去弄车牌号吧。噢，天哪。噢，我一定是累坏了。抱歉。
Later, Lissa told me she was exhausted. She hadn't slept in days, and she was getting desperate. It had been three days since she posted Suna's name on Facebook. She just lost it. When Suna called the next afternoon, he sounded different.
后来，莉莎告诉我她精疲力尽。她已经好几天没睡了，而且变得越来越绝望。距离她在 Facebook 上发布苏纳的名字已经过去三天了。她彻底崩溃了。当苏纳第二天下午打来电话时，他的声音变了。
Sierra Crane Murdoch. Coming up, Suna's new tactic. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
塞拉·克兰·默多克。接下来，苏纳的新策略。广告后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目将继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "A Mess To Be Reckoned With." Sierra Crane Murdoch is telling the story of Lissa Yellow Bird, as Lissa investigates the disappearance of her niece in 2016. And we pick up where we left off in Lissa's investigation. Here's Sierra.
这是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是“一个要收拾的烂摊子”。塞拉·克兰·默多克正在讲述莉莎·黄鸟的故事，当时莉莎正在调查她侄女在 2016 年的失踪案。我们从莉莎调查中断的地方继续。下面是塞拉。
On day four, Suna calls Lissa again, and something's changed.
第四天，苏纳又给莉莎打了电话，情况发生了变化。
Good afternoon.
下午好。
Hey.
嘿。
Can you be at Spirit Lake tomorrow morning or tomorrow afternoon?
明天早上或明天下午你能到灵魂湖来吗？
Huh?
啊？
Can you come to Spirit Lake tomorrow afternoon?
明天下午你能来灵魂湖吗？
Why?
为什么？
I'm gonna come forward with everything clear with you.
我打算把一切真相都告诉你。
Oh, yeah?
噢，是吗？
Yep. You're too good of a lady, and I'm not going to lie to you, not going to continue. And I'm not going to hold a lie from you.
是的。你是个太好的女士，我不想骗你，不会再继续了。我不会再向你隐瞒什么。
So do you know something?
那你真的知道什么吗？
I already talked to a Detective Jose. I told her to come over here tomorrow afternoon. I told her I was going to contact you and ask you to be up here also.
我已经跟何塞侦探谈过了。我告诉她明天下午过来。我告诉她我会联系你，让你也过来。
OK.
好的。
Because I wanted to talk to all you guys at the same time, as well as my family and all that.
因为我想同时和你们所有人谈谈，还有我的家人之类的。
Are you involved?
你参与了吗？
No, I wasn't.
没有，我没有。
But you know where she's at?
但你知道她在哪里吗？
I was there. I was there, but I didn't know that was going to happen. It should never happened. And I know where the body's at. I know who the individual that did it.
我在场。我在场，但我不知道会发生那种事。那不应该发生的。我知道尸体在哪里。我知道是谁做的。
You better tell them everything you know, otherwise you're going to get the blame. You know that.
你最好把你知道的一切告诉他们，否则你会背锅的。你知道的。
That's why I want you there. And I wanted to approach you with these cops around and letting them know that you're the main one I want to talk to. And after I talk with you guys and give you guys my statement about everything, then we're going to go. I'm going to take you guys to the body.
这就是为什么我希望你在场。我想在警察在场的情况下找你，让他们知道你是我最想谈话的人。在我跟你们谈完并提供陈述后，我们就会去。我会带你们去尸体所在地。
You know what? I'm sorry. And you know what? I cried my head off earlier. And you know what? I just remember and think about your laughing and your sense of humor last night.
你知道吗？抱歉。你知道吗？我早些时候哭得死去活来。你知道吗？我刚才回想起你昨晚的笑声和幽默感。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
That's what's make--
那是让——
When I was acting deliriously tired?
当我表现得困得神志不清时？
Yeah.
是啊。
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑声] 是的。
And that's the reason why I-- I mean, I'm doing this.
那也是我这么做的原因。
Suna, you know this is like another chance for you to turn it all around, right?
苏纳，你知道这又是你扭转一切的机会，对吧？
I do. But all I'm asking for is protection once I step forward, as well as my family.
我知道。但我唯一要求的是，当我站出来后，给我和我的家人保护。
If this sounds at all manipulative to you, it did to me too, like he's flattering her, saying Lissa finally convinced him to do the right thing. And then he asks, so what can you do for me after I've done this thing for you? But Lissa goes along with it.
如果这听起来像是一种操纵，对我来说也一样，好像他在奉承她，说莉莎终于说服他做正确的事了。然后他问，那么你为我做了这事之后能为我做什么？但莉莎顺着他的意思说了下去。
Well, the only thing I can guarantee you is that my family will not retaliate against your family.
嗯，我唯一能保证的是我的家人不会报复你的家人。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
I don't hold any ill will to your parents. I don't even hold any ill will to you. I know you've lied to me already. I knew you're getting high. And I know people don't make the best decisions when they're high. This is your time to turn it all around, you know what I mean?
我对你的父母没有任何恶意。我甚至对你都没有恶意。我知道你已经骗过我了。我知道你在吸毒。我知道人们在吸毒时做不出最好的决定。这是你扭转一切的时候了，你明白吗？
I do.
我明白。
Whether it's making bad decisions, whether it's sexual impulses or not, whatever, whatever it is that gets you into these predicaments. How old are you?
无论是因为做出错误的决定，无论是因为性冲动还是其他什么，无论是什么让你陷入这些困境。你多大了？
I'm going to be 38 years old next month.
下个月我就 38 岁了。
38. You got plenty of time to turn that shit around.
38 了。你有足够的时间去扭转那些狗屁事。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
Suna says he's not ready to tell her what happened, but Lissa's worried he'll have a change of heart overnight, back out. Plus, Suna says people are after him. It was possible he'd get killed before he confessed the next day, and then they'd never find Carla's body.
苏纳说他还没准备好告诉她发生了什么，但莉莎担心他一夜之间会改变主意，会反悔。再说，苏纳说有人在跟踪他。他很有可能在明天忏悔之前就被杀掉，那样就永远找不到卡拉的尸体了。
So Lissa keeps pressing him. She throws out a name, Dakota Charbonneau. People have told her Suna often hung around Dakota. He was notorious in Spirit Lake, with a record of violent crime. Lissa thought maybe he's the one who actually murdered Carla.
所以莉莎不断地追问他。她抛出了一个名字，达科塔·沙博诺（Dakota Charbonneau）。人们告诉她苏纳经常和达科塔混在一起。他在灵魂湖很有名，有暴力犯罪前科。莉莎想也许是他才是真正谋杀卡拉的人。
Who was with you guys? Dakota and who?
你们还有谁在一起？达科塔和谁？
Like I said, I'll give that name--
就像我说的，我会给那个名字——
Charbonneau?
沙博诺？
I'll give the names tomorrow.
我明天会给名字。
Not going to give me a name? Fine, Lissa thinks. She keeps pressing him.
不给名字？好吧，莉莎想。她继续紧逼。
Why did he do it, though? What possessed him to do that?
但他为什么那么做？是什么让他做出那种事？
These guys just figured that she had dope and she had money. How much dope did she have? I don't know. How much money she had? I don't know. I wasn't sure. I never seen nothing.
这些人以为她有毒品和钱。她带了多少毒品？我不知道。她有多少钱？我不知道。我没确定。我没看见任何东西。
I mean, I'm like, what the fuck, man? I mean, it shocked the shit out of me. I mean, they did it behind my back. And when I heard the gunshot, and it just happened to be her.
我是说，我当时心想，妈的，伙计。这简直把我吓坏了。我是说，他们背着我干的。当我听到枪声时，偏偏就是她。
Well, did she make any noises? Or did she cry, or anything?
好吧，她发出什么声音了吗？或者她哭了，什么的？
The rest of this phone call is really hard to listen to. For the first time in four days, you hear Lissa's voice crack, but she keeps going, asks question after question. She gets Suna to tell her almost everything. He says one of the other guys shot her, took her drugs. Then he says he got away from the guys as fast as he could. Lissa asks him, did you go back and check on Carla, see if she was alive? Suna says, no.
这个电话接下来的部分非常难听。四天来，莉莎的声音第一次颤抖，但她坚持下去，问了一个又一个问题。她让苏纳告诉了她几乎一切。他说其中一个人开了枪，拿走了她的毒品。然后他说他尽可能快地逃离了那些人。莉莎问他，你回去看卡拉了吗，看看她是否还活着？苏纳说，没有。
When he told you that, how did you feel?
当他告诉你这些时，你感觉如何？
I wanted to know every detail. So I wanted to know, did she suffer? What if she suffered? I made a promise to Chucky that I would look out for her. And so, I guess it was important to me to know how badly I failed at that.
我想知道每一个细节。所以我想要知道，她受罪了吗？如果她受罪了怎么办？我曾答应查基我会照顾她。所以，我想知道我在这件事上失败得有多惨对我来说很重要。
And if she was out there suffering for days, then it would have made it tougher. But I wanted to believe that she went fast and that she didn't know. It's kind of hard to know that. Even that, as ugly as it can be, it would offer a little bit of comfort. I needed to hear that.
如果她在那儿受罪了几天，那会更让人难受。但我想要相信她走得很快，没意识到发生了什么。这很难说。即使是那样，尽管听起来很丑陋，但它能提供一点点安慰。我需要听到那个。
Lissa stayed on the phone with Suna for a lot of that night. And it's during this call that she softens toward him, like her anger has totally drained out of her. Later, Lissa would tell me she was afraid Suna was going to hurt himself or do something stupid to get himself hurt. She needed him to make it to the next day.
莉莎那天晚上和苏纳通了很长时间电话。正是在这次通话中，她对他软化了，就像她的愤怒完全从她身上抽走了一样。后来，莉莎告诉我她担心苏纳会伤害自己或者做些傻事导致自己受伤。她需要他坚持到第二天。
Could I ask you a question?
我可以问你个问题吗？
Shoot it.
问吧。
What are you going to ask of me? What are you going to ask be done to me?
你打算要求我做什么？你打算要求对我做什么惩罚？
What am I going ask, like punishment-wise, or what?
你是说，惩罚方面，还是什么？
Yeah.
是啊。
I mean, for you, I think you have somewhat of a conscience left, you know what I mean? I think you should, you know, maybe even get some kind of immunity for turning state's evidence against the other two.
我是说，对你，我想你多少还剩下点良知，你明白吗？我想你应该，你知道，也许甚至能因为出面指证另外两人而获得某种豁免权。
What's that? Immunity?
那是什么？豁免权？
Immunity is when they-- [SIGHS] Immunity-- OK, do you know what a proffer agreement is?
豁免权是当他们——[叹气] 豁免权——好了，你知道什么是辩诉交易吗？
Yeah.
知道。
Do you?
知道？
I mean, not really, but--
我是说，不完全是，但——
Well, don't just agree with me, tell me, do you know what a proffer agreement is?
嗯，别只是附和我就行，告诉我，你知道什么是辩诉交易吗？
No, I don't.
不，我不知道。
A proffer agreement is when you go in--
辩诉交易是当你去的时候——
She starts explaining his options in a system that she knows, and he doesn't.
她开始在一个她了解、而他不了解的系统中为他解释选择。
P-R-O-F-F-E-R-- you can look that shit up on the internet.
P-R-O-F-F-E-R——你可以在网上查查那个词。
Mm-hm.
嗯哼。
You can ask for a proffer. And if I were you, I would.
你可以要求辩诉交易。如果是我，我会的。
Couldn't you, when we're sitting there talking to them, I mean, mention that also?
当我们坐下来和他们谈的时候，不能提到那个吗？
I could.
我可以提。
You know what? The only thing I ask is that-- it's my little boy's birthday Saturday. I'd love to be there. My little boy's going to be three years old.
你知道吗？我唯一的要求是——周六是我小儿子的生日。我真的很想在那里。我小儿子要三岁了。
You can't lie. You can't lie.
你不能撒谎。你不能撒谎。
I won't.
我不会的。
Everything that comes out of your mouth needs to be the truth. Because if they find out later that it wasn't, it nullifies the agreement.
你嘴里说的每一件事都必须是真话。因为如果他们以后发现不是，协议就作废了。
I understand. What I'm saying is that I'd like to spend my little boy's birthday with him, you know what I mean?
我明白。我说的是我想和我小儿子一起过他的生日，你明白吗？
If you do everything you say you're going to do, I will fight for you to be there, with my heart and soul.
如果你做了你承诺的一切，我会全心全意地为你争取去那里的权利。
I give you my word.
我向你保证。
And keeping in mind you've given me your word before.
记住你以前也给过我承诺。
This is my word where I'm stepping forward and giving only but honesty, honesty that your family deserves, Carla deserves.
这是我的承诺，我站出来，只提供诚实，这是你的家人、卡拉应得的诚实。
If you do that, I will--
如果你那样做，我会——
I don't want my kid growing up without me.
我不想让我的孩子在没有我的情况下长大。
If you'll keep your word, I will keep mine.
如果你遵守诺言，我也会遵守我的。
And I will tomorrow.
明天我会的。
Lissa left for Spirit Lake the next morning at 7:00. It was a two-hour drive, and she called me. We talked the whole time. She told me she felt like all her searching for missing people had prepared her for this moment.
莉莎第二天早上 7 点出发去灵魂湖。这是两小时的车程，她给我打了电话。我们聊了一路。她告诉我她感觉她寻找失踪人员的经历为她准备好了这一刻。
When she got to the reservation, FBI agents were already there. Suna had brought them to Carla's body. The crime scene was taped off. It was in a wooded area, the ground marked with old tire tracks. Carla lay no more than 50 yards from the road. People had been driving right past her for weeks.
当她到达保留地时，联邦调查局的人已经在那里了。苏纳带他们找到了卡拉的尸体。犯罪现场被拉起了警戒线。它在一个树木繁茂的区域，地面上留着旧轮胎印。卡拉离公路不超过 50 码。人们已经在她身边开车经过了好几个星期。
The agents didn't let Lissa get close to Carla. Instead, they brought her pictures to make the identification. Carla was in bad shape. Lissa barely recognized her. And then Lissa saw the ring, the big, gaudy ring she had gotten after Carla for.
调查员没让莉莎靠近卡拉。相反，他们拿给她照片让她辨认。卡拉的情况很糟糕。莉莎几乎认不出她了。然后莉莎看到了那枚戒指，她因为这枚戒指曾找过卡拉麻烦的那枚大而俗气的戒指。
The whole thing was just senseless. I remember telling Suna, why didn't you guys just call us? We would have gave you the money just to let her go.
整件事简直毫无意义。我记得我对苏纳说，你们为什么不直接打给我们？我们本会给你们钱只要你们放她走。
[EMOTIONAL]
[情绪激动]
She might have been a little shit, but she was important to us, you know? And I remember standing there for a minute, thinking like, what the fuck am I doing way out here by myself?
她可能有点像个小混蛋，但她对我们很重要，你知道吗？我记得在那站了一分钟，心想，我一个人在这荒郊野外到底在干什么？
Lissa had never minded searching for missing people on her own before, but now, suddenly, she felt very alone. She drove down the road to where Suna was waiting for her with several investigators and his family. His mom thanked Lissa. They huddled together as Suna made his confession.
莉莎以前从不介意独自寻找失踪人员，但现在，突然间，她感到非常孤独。她开车下路去苏纳和几名调查员及其家人等候的地方。他的妈妈感谢了莉莎。当苏纳做出供述时，他们蜷缩在一起。
Lissa was watching Suna, his rapid speech. She thought he seemed traumatized. She also thought he was telling the truth. And when he was done, he came up to Lissa.
莉莎看着苏纳，他说话很快。她觉得他看起来受到了创伤。她也觉得他在说真话。当他讲完后，他走到莉莎跟前。
He said, I hate to sound so selfish, but I really want to know. Am I going to go to jail today? And I don't know. It seemed like that question kind of made the agents mad.
他说，我不想显得那么自私，但我真的很想知道。我今天会去坐牢吗？我不知道。那个问题似乎让调查员们很生气。
They kind of came over and started talking to me. And they were like, well, Lissa, what do you want? And I said, well, if he's the one that's helping me bring my niece home, then I would like to see him stay-- stay out.
他们过来开始跟我谈话。他们问，那么，Lissa，你想要什么？我说，好吧，如果他是那个帮助我把侄女带回家的人，那么我希望看到他留下来——自由。
That's what the agents did. As Lissa was leaving the reservation, she stopped at Devil's Lake, this vast body of water that blends in with the flatness of the prairie around it. She got out of the car, walked to the edge.
调查员们就是这么做的。当莉莎离开保留地时，她在魔鬼湖（Devil's Lake）停了下来，这片广阔的水域与周围平坦的草原融为一体。她下了车，走到边缘。
And I just looked out there 'cause it's pretty there. I like that territory. There's a lot of spirituality there too. And I just couldn't feel anything.
我只是看着那里，因为那里很美。我喜欢那片土地。那里也有很多灵性。但我什么都感觉不到。
I kept thinking. While I was by that water, I thought, just one feeling, just do one feeling. If you could feel one thing, even if it's hate, or anger, or something, Lissa, just come up with one feeling, because I think there's something wrong with you.
我一直在想。当我在那水边时，我想，就一种感觉，哪怕只有一种感觉。如果你能感觉到什么，哪怕是恨，或者怒，或者什么的，Lissa，哪怕只有一种感觉，因为我觉得你出问题了。
[EMOTIONAL] And the only feeling I could feel was gratefulness, gratefulness to Suna that she didn't have to spend another day out there alone. So I put a cigarette down for Carla, and I smoked one, and I left.
[情绪激动] 我唯一能感觉到的就是感激，感激苏纳，让她不必在那儿独自度过又一天。所以我给卡拉放下了一根烟，我自己也抽了一根，然后离开了。
Another reason Lissa still hardly tells anyone about this case, a reason why it's still so hard for her has to do with what came afterward. Lissa went to Carla's funeral. Loretta, Carla's mom, thanked Lissa, honored her with a star quilt. But then what happened was a kind of unraveling.
莉莎至今几乎不告诉任何人这个案子的另一个原因，以及它为何对她来说依然如此艰难，与后来发生的事有关。莉莎参加了卡拉的葬礼。卡拉的妈妈洛蕾塔感谢了莉莎，送给她一张星形被子。但随后发生的是一种分崩离析。
Prosecutors began building their case against Suna and the two other guys responsible for Carla's murder. And Lissa became the main point of contact for Carla's family. She started going to all the legal meetings, helping Carla's mom understand what was going on. And at the same time, Lissa was still talking to Suna, constantly.
检察官开始构建针对苏纳和另外两个卡拉谋杀案负责人的案件。而莉莎成了卡拉家人的主要联络人。她开始参加所有的法律会议，帮助卡拉的妈妈了解进展。与此同时，莉莎还在不断地和苏纳通话。
But my phone's ready to go dead here.
但我的手机快没电了。
OK.
好的。
And if you want to chit-chat throughout the night, I don't mind. I mean, I'm just as well tired too, though, because I stayed up most of the night last night thinking that these guys were going to come through.
如果你整晚都想聊天，我不介意。我是说，我也很累了，因为我昨晚几乎整晚没睡，担心那些人会找过来。
Yeah. I haven't been sleeping well either.
是啊。我也睡得不好。
I mean, I don't know. I mean, I'm going to try to sleep some or whatever I can tonight and all that, but--
我是说，我不知道。我是说，我打算今晚试着睡一会儿或者什么的，但我——
Yeah. I probably will. If I head out tonight, I'll probably call you just for--
是啊。我可能会。如果我今晚出去，我会给你打电话，只为——
Just to keep being known that I'm still here, you know what I mean?
只是为了让人知道我还在，你明白吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
At first, Lissa had a pragmatic reason to keep talking to Suna. She needed him to follow through, to testify in Carla's case against the two other guys involved. Lissa worried for Suna's safety. He wanted witness protection, so she started calling around on his behalf.
起初，莉莎与苏纳保持通话有实用的理由。她需要他坚持到底，在卡拉的案子中出庭指证另外两人。莉莎担心苏纳的安全。他想要证人保护，所以她开始代表他四处奔走。
When the prosecutor found out about this, that Lissa was advocating for Suna, she made Carla's mom, Loretta, the spokesperson for the family and stopped inviting Lissa to meetings, basically iced Lissa out. The court stopped notifying Lissa about hearings in Carla's case. Court officials told her, we only do that for the victim's immediate family.
当检察官发现这一点——莉莎在为苏纳辩护——时，她让卡拉的妈妈洛蕾塔成为家人的代言人，并停止邀请莉莎参加会议，基本上把莉莎晾在了一边。法院停止通知莉莎关于卡拉案子的听证会。法庭官员告诉她，我们只针对受害者的直系亲属。
Suna pled guilty to felony murder, meaning he committed a crime that led to Carla's death, even if he didn't intend to murder her. Prosecutors said that Suna didn't plan to murder Carla. He didn't have the gun. He didn't pull the trigger. What Suna planned to do, prosecutors argued, was to rob Carla of drugs.
苏纳对重罪谋杀罪表示认罪，这意味着他犯下了一项导致卡拉死亡的犯罪，即使他并非有意谋杀。检察官表示，苏纳没计划谋杀卡拉。他没有枪。他没扣动扳机。苏纳计划做的是抢劫卡拉的毒品，检察官辩称。
The other two men involved in Carla's murder, they pled out after Suna informed on them. They got 50 and 28-year sentences for a list of charges that included use of a firearm, conspiracy to commit robbery, and second-degree murder.
涉及卡拉谋杀案的另外两个男人，在苏纳举报他们后认罪。他们被判处 50 年和 28 年徒刑，罪名清单包括持有火器、合谋抢劫和二级谋杀。
At Suna's sentencing hearing, Lissa sat behind Carla's mother, sister, and a few of Carla's kids. Lissa gave a statement, and she actually spoke on Suna's behalf. She had wanted him to get probation on a lesser charge. Lissa said, I was the person who brought Carla home, and it wouldn't have happened without Suna.
在苏纳的量刑听证会上，莉莎坐在卡拉的妈妈、姐姐和几个卡拉的孩子后面。莉莎作了陈述，她实际上是为苏纳说话的。她曾想让他以较轻的罪名获得缓刑。莉莎说，我就是把卡拉带回家的人，没有苏纳就不会有这一切。
She said, I can tell you, a lot of our people are still laying in fields and behind bushes all over this country, and nobody cares. She told the judge it was so rare for people like Suna to come forward, to tell the truth. She asked him to show compassion to Suna, because she said he showed compassion to us.
她说，我可以告诉你，我们的人民中还有许多人躺在全国各地的田野里和灌木丛后，没人关心。她告诉法官，像苏纳这样出面说真话的人太稀少了。她要求他对苏纳表现出慈悲，因为她说他向我们表现出了慈悲。
The rest of the hearing, Carla's mother and sister wouldn't even look at Lissa. Lissa kept tapping Loretta on the shoulder, but Loretta just stared ahead, ignored her.
在听证会的其余时间里，卡拉的妈妈和姐姐甚至不看莉莎。莉莎不断拍洛蕾塔的肩膀，但洛蕾塔只是盯着前方，无视她。
Loretta was pissed.
洛蕾塔被惹毛了。
How did you know Loretta was pissed?
你怎么知道洛蕾塔被惹毛了？
Because they all got on Facebook like right outside that court room and were like, Lissa Yellow Bird is over here taking the side of the murderer against my daughter. And then that kind of went out.
因为他们就在那个法庭外面都上了 Facebook 说，莉莎·黄鸟居然站在杀人犯那边来对付我的女儿。然后那事就传开了。
How did you feel when you saw those posts?
当你看到那些帖子时，你感觉如何？
I was just like, well, there's been a few families, and she's one of them, where just 100% ungratefulness. But I delivered. Suna didn't kill Carla. I don't have to explain myself to anybody. They weren't there. They didn't have to negotiate with anybody to get their loved one back.
我只是想，嗯，有几个家庭——她是其中之一——表现得百分之百忘恩负义。但我完成了任务。苏纳没杀卡拉。我不需要向任何人解释我自己。他们不在场。他们不用跟任何人谈判来带回他们的亲人。
Loretta wouldn't talk to me for this story. I reached out to her several times. She didn't respond.
洛蕾塔不愿与我谈论这个故事。我多次联系她。她没回应。
Suna was sentenced to 15 years, which is actually a pretty lenient sentence for felony murder, but Lissa was furious. I've never heard her as angry at anyone as she was at the prosecutor in this case, a woman named Jan Morley. Lissa called Jan a slithering snake who was out to get Suna, typical of federal officials who fail tribal communities. So I called Jan, the prosecutor. She's retired now.
苏纳被判了 15 年，这对于重罪谋杀来说其实算是一个相当从轻的判决，但莉莎非常愤怒。我从来没听过她对任何人像对这个案子的检察官那样愤怒，那个女人叫简·莫利（Jan Morley）。莉莎称简为一条想要搞定苏纳的滑行毒蛇，这是联邦官员不顾部落社区利益的典型表现。所以我给简打了电话，那个检察官。她现在退休了。
I'm Native American, my background.
我是美洲原住民，我的背景。
Oh, really?
哦，真的吗？
Yes. Right. Grew up on the Turtle Mountain Indian Reservation, Belcourt, North Dakota. It's 10 miles from the Canadian border.
是的。没错。在北达科他州贝尔库特的龟山印第安保留地长大。距离加拿大边境 10 英里。
Wow. I didn't realize that.
哇。我没意识到。
Lissa didn't realize it either. I asked her later. She sounded surprised. Lissa had told me that in her conversations with Suna, she had begun to see him as a vulnerable adult maybe with a cognitive disability, but Jan didn't see him this way.
莉莎也没意识到。我后来问了她。她听起来很惊讶。莉莎曾告诉我，在她和苏纳的谈话中，她开始把他看作一个可能患有认知障碍的弱势成年人，但简并没有这样看他。
Suna is not a victim in this case. Suna came forward because Suna wanted to save Suna's skin.
苏纳不是此案的受害者。苏纳之所以出面，是因为苏纳想保住自己的小命。
Do you think-- you know, he said he was scared. How do you feel about that?
你认为——你知道，他说他很害怕。你对此有什么感觉？
I don't believe it. I don't think he was scared. He didn't leave immediately. He stayed there. They went through her stuff. He wanted to be part of the loot.
我不信。我不觉得他害怕。他没立即离开。他留在那里了。他们翻了她的东西。他想要分赃。
So he spent a lot of time right after Carla was killed with them, you're saying?
所以你是说，卡拉被杀后他跟他们在一起待了很长时间？
Yeah. They cleaned the car. They disposed of their clothing. He wanted the-- the-- because Suna-- this is Suna. Suna's shoes were new. And they wanted Suna to take his coat off and burn his shoes too, because Suna must have had some blood on his shoes, but Suna wouldn't burn his new shoes. [LAUGHS]
是啊。他们清理了车。他们处理了衣服。他想要——因为苏纳——这就是苏纳。苏纳的鞋子是新的。他们想让苏纳脱掉外套烧掉他的鞋子，因为苏纳鞋上一定沾了血，但苏纳不愿烧掉他的新鞋。[笑声]
Wow. Was that from text messages? Were you seeing Suna writing text messages, being like, no, I don't want to go burn my shoes?
哇。那是从短信中发现的吗？你是看到苏纳发短信说，不，我不要去烧我的鞋吗？
No. Suna told us about that.
不。苏纳告诉我们的。
Oh, interesting. Huh.
哦，真有意思。哈。
He said, my shoes are new. I wasn't going to burn my new shoes.
他说，我的鞋子是新的。我不打算烧我的新鞋。
Lissa was right, actually. Jan had made up her mind about Suna even before Carla's murder. She had prosecuted his rape case 15 years earlier. Jan said it was violent. She remembered this when she began prosecuting Carla's case.
莉莎其实是对的。简在卡拉谋杀案之前就对苏纳有了定论。她在 15 年前起诉过他的强奸案。简说那是暴力犯罪。她在开始起诉卡拉的案子时记起了这一点。
Suna is very conniving. I wanted Suna to be incarcerated after his plea, but he talked me out of it. And I can't believe he talked me out of it, but he did. It was like, honest to god, Janice, I'll this and-- he always called me by my first name too, called me Janice-- honest to god.
苏纳非常阴险。我本来想在他认罪后把他关起来，但他劝我不要。我不信他劝动了我，但他确实做到了。他就像是，诚实地对你，贾妮斯（Janice），我保证我会……——他总是直呼我的名字，叫我贾妮斯——诚实地对你。
And he is one of the most untruthful people I have ever run across. He lies. He lies right to your face. And he'll continue, until you actually have to take the evidence, put it in his face and say, this is the evidence.
他是那种我所见过的最不诚实的人之一。他撒谎。他当着你的面撒谎。而且他会继续撒，直到你不得不拿出证据，甩在他脸上说，这就是证据。
The evidence in Carla's case is this. In the days before Carla was killed, Suna exchanged hundreds of text messages with Dakota Charbonneau, planning how to rob Carla.
卡拉案中的证据是这样的。在卡拉被杀前的几天，苏纳与达科塔·沙博诺交换了数百条短信，计划如何抢劫卡拉。
The prosecution argued that the murder was an accident. The other guy with them that night tried to threaten Carla with a gun, and the gun went off. But afterward, Suna and Dakota traded more messages about how to cover it up, Jan said.
控方辩称谋杀是一场意外。当晚与他们在一起的另一个男人试图用枪威胁卡拉，结果枪走火了。但事后，苏纳和达科塔交换了更多关于如何掩盖真相的短信，简说。
I didn't get to see the evidence, but the story Jan told me seemed so different from the one Suna told Lissa. I didn't know if Lissa knew all of this, so I shared it with her.
我没机会看到证据，但简告诉我的故事似乎和苏纳告诉莉莎的那个版本大相径庭。我不知道莉莎是否知道这一切，所以我分享给了她。
Does it change anything for you?
这对你有什么改变吗？
Well, no, it doesn't. I mean, it's not like it's any new information being presented here. I'm sure Suna did want his money. I'm sure he did want drugs. Isn't that what he was there for in the beginning? Do I know that Suna's a sexual deviant? I do. Does that make him a murderer?
嗯，没有。我是说，这又不是什么新的信息。我相信苏纳确实想要钱。我相信他确实想要毒品。他当初去那儿不就是为了那个吗？我知道苏纳是个性变态吗？我知道。这让他成为谋杀犯吗？
Yeah, but he was at least partially responsible for Carla's death, right? Doesn't that matter?
是啊，但他至少部分对卡拉的死负有责任，对吧？那难道不重要吗？
My position is I'm unmoved. I am totally unmoved.
我的立场是我不为所动。我完全不为所动。
Lissa's now helping Suna's lawyer prepare an appeal. When I talked to Suna, he told me that he now looks to Lissa like a mom. He still calls her Lisa, but they speak almost every week. Meanwhile, Lissa and Carla's mother, Loretta, they don't speak anymore.
莉莎现在正在帮助苏纳的律师准备上诉。当我跟苏纳谈话时，他告诉我他现在把莉莎看作妈妈。他依然叫她 Lisa，但他们几乎每周都通话。与此同时，莉莎和卡拉的妈妈洛蕾塔，她们不再说话了。
Is there any part of you that understands why they're angry?
你有一部分理解他们为什么生气吗？
This is what I say to people every single time when they ask for my help. What are you willing to do to get your loved one back? What are you willing for me to do to get your loved one back? And you know what the answer always is? Anything. Anything.
这就是我每次在被请求帮助时对人们说的话。你愿意付出什么代价来找回你的亲人？你愿意我做什么来找回你的亲人？你知道答案总是什么吗？什么都行。什么都行。
And it's always at the end when they get what they want when the conditions come out. Because in the beginning, you said you wanted to do anything. You were willing for me to do anything to get your loved one home. And I did that.
而且总是在最后，当他们得到他们想要的，条件就会浮现。因为一开始，你说你什么都愿意做。你愿意我做任何事来让你的亲人回家。我做到了。
In this case, the anything Lissa did was to connect with Suna, to get him to trust her. Lissa's sympathy for Suna doesn't surprise me. The thing that drives her to look for people no one else is looking for, it's the same thing that drew her to Suna.
在这个案子里，莉莎做的“任何事”就是与苏纳建立联系，让他信任她。莉莎对苏纳的同情并没让我感到意外。那种驱使她去寻找没人找的人的动力，与把她引向苏纳的动力是同一件事。
I asked Lissa once, why do you do this work? She said, it makes me happy. It makes me happy to help these people who have no hope left in this world. She couldn't save Chucky, she couldn't save Carla, but maybe she could still save Suna.
我曾经问莉莎，你为什么要做这份工作？她说，它让我快乐。能帮助这些在这个世界上已经绝望的人让我感到快乐。她救不了查基，她救不了卡拉，但也许她还能救苏纳。
Sierra Crane Murdoch. Her book about Lissa, which covers that first incredibly eventful case that Lissa did, it talks about Lissa and her family in so much more detail than we ever were able to cover here today in an hour. It is called Yellow Bird-- Oil, Murder, and a Woman's Search for Justice in Indian Country.
塞拉·克兰·默多克。她那本关于莉莎的书，涵盖了莉莎做的那个充满了戏剧性的第一起案件，书中对莉莎及其家人的描述比我们今天在一小时节目中提到的细节要丰富得多。书名叫《黄鸟——石油、谋杀与一个女人在印第安地界对正义的追寻》（Yellow Bird: Oil, Murder, and a Woman's Search for Justice in Indian Country）。
Our program was produced today by Lilly Sullivan. The people who created today's show include Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Aviva DeKornfeld, Noor Gill, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, Miki Meek, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katharine Rae Mondo, Ben Phelan, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Nancy Updike. Our managing editors are Diane Wu and Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum.
我们今天的节目由莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）制作。参与创作今天节目的还有苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔洪（Ben Calhoun）、达娜·齐维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、努尔·吉尔（Noor Gill）、达米安·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、丽娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katharine Rae Mondo）、本·费伦（Ben Phelan）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）以及南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。我们的执行主编是黛安·吴（Diane Wu）和萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的执行编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。
Special thanks today to Paul Yellow Bird McCormick, Shawna Yellow Bird, Jessie Yellow Bird, April Bowman, Sarah Koenig, Brian Reed, Connie Walker, Pat Hogue, Bianca Giaever, Lauren Markham, Charles Hudson, Allison Cohen, Terray Sylvester, Sarah Deer, Zaneta Thayer, and Jessica Lussenhop.
今天特别感谢保罗·黄鸟·麦考密克（Paul Yellow Bird McCormick）、肖娜·黄鸟（Shawna Yellow Bird）、杰西·黄鸟（Jessie Yellow Bird）、阿普里尔·鲍曼（April Bowman）、萨拉·科尼格（Sarah Koenig）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、康妮·沃克（Connie Walker）、帕特·霍格（Pat Hogue）、比安卡·贾弗（Bianca Giaever）、劳伦·马克姆（Lauren Markham）、查尔斯·哈德森（Charles Hudson）、艾莉森·科恩（Allison Cohen）、泰雷·西尔维斯特（Terray Sylvester）、萨拉·迪尔（Sarah Deer）、扎内塔·塞耶（Zaneta Thayer）和杰西卡·卢森霍普（Jessica Lussenhop）。
Our website, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，在那里您可以免费流媒体收听我们 700 多集的存档，thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由 PRX 公共广播交换中心提供给公共广播电台。
Special thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he is amazed at how much more efficient he is working from home-- no more getting up at the crack of dawn, climbing the radio station's broadcast tower every morning to check the temperature and wind conditions.
特别感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，一如既往。你知道吗，他对自己在家里办公的效率之高感到惊奇——不用再在凌晨时分起床，每天早晨爬上电台的广播塔去检查温度和风力情况了。
You can look that shit up on the internet.
你可以在网上查查那个词。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带来更多《这就是美国生活》的故事。